j'avais remarqué que michael jackson
avait vendu à peu près 450 millions
d'albums qu'il était deuxième au top 50
et un soir j'étais au restaurant avec ma
femme et je lui ai dit michael jackson
on va programmer michael jackson
et ça a marché formidable et à quoi ça
tient quand même ce qui s'appelle et xla
ce qui s'appelle avoir vraiment du pif
et à cet égard j'ai une surprise pour
vous un des vétérans du paf ravoux
décerner la médaille de grand pif tuba à
pourrait compenser cet exploit mais en
pas eu de sept d'or j'en suis ravie
professeur savez un 7 d'or c'est pas
grand chose un grand pic du paf c'est
beaucoup mieux
très plaisir
parce que nous à moi c'est la télévision
2 et oui ça mais ce n'est pas mme
russell mais celui-là ce très minces
ardisson thierry wident de nice alpes
maritimes
oui j'ai l'honneur de vous remettre au
nom du peuple français
le pif du paf merci pour la bonne idée
qu avait eu la semaine dernière
vous n'avez pas d'une grossièreté ce qui
est rare on n'avait pas fait un jeu de
mots vilain vous avez respecté ou à peu
près la langue française continue et
thierry égyptien mais la bière jackson
surtout merci les routes ça me touche
beaucoup merci beaucoup
bravo
je voulais
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu